[موسيقى]
الآن السيد حكيمي
يفترض بوضوح ما يريد الأبرياء
ليقول أنه متهم بذلك
يعني أن التحقيق جار و
تم وضعه من قبل قاضي التحقيق
تحت الرقابة القضائية
القضاء يعني أننا نفرض عليه
عدد معين من الالتزامات و / أو
من الحظر في هذه الحالة لديه
ممنوع من الاتصال
هذه الشابة لكنه لم يفعل
تحريمه أو مزاولة مهنته
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
فقط تريد أن تذهب على الفور
الاستلقاء على طاولة الفحص
الطبيب للذهاب والقيام
التحقيقات الطبية هو فعل
وهو عنيف للغاية
تطفلية ويمكن أن تكون شديدة
صدمة للضحية التي تأتي
شجب بالفعل أعمال الاغتصاب حتى انه
هناك مجموعة كاملة من الأسباب التي يمكن أن
تعال واشرح لماذا الضحية
إما أن يسحب شكواه أو لا يرغب
لا تخضع للتحقيقات التي
من الواضح أن هذا جنبًا إلى جنب مع
المحققون والقاضي
مدرب
[موسيقى]
لم يكن اختيار القاضي
المدرب الذي اختار المكان
السيد الحكيمي تحت الرقابة القضائية
بدون قياس هذا سوار ما
يبدو منطقيًا نسبيًا لأننا
يعلم أنه سيُطلب منه السفر و
أنه يحتاج إلى إجازة من عمله
تركيب سوار المنزل هو
شيء مقيد للغاية
ليقول إنك ملزم
الجداول الزمنية لديك سوار في
الوتد المتصل بغلاف
الهاتف لمنفذ الزوجين الخاص بك
[موسيقى]